et on commence avec cette information
insolite des chevreuils ivre mais oui
mais gênez-vous alors on est au
printemps ça nous a pas échappé et qui
dit printemps dit bourgeons qui dit
bourgeons du chevreuil le chevreuil
adore les bourgeons alors autant les
serres il y a aucun problème il mange de
l'herbe autant les chevreuils sont très
friands de bourgeons alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe
ils peuvent en manger jusqu'à 2000 par
jour je sais pas comment on a pu compter
ça mais c'est un chiffre que j'ai vu
alors il se battre excusez-moi du terme
et et si bourré de sucre un bourgeon et
ce sont des ruminants donc les bourgeons
restent dans leur penses voilà et au
bout d'un moment ça fermente et qui dit
fermentation dit alcool qui dit alcool
dit vrai voilà donc on peut trouver en
ce moment des chevreuils avec des
comportements pour le moment étrange un
peu un peu berlué un peu perdu qui
peuvent aussi se retrouver dans un
jardin ou irré dans les rues d'un
village etc et alors si en plus ils ont
avalé des bourgeons de Bourdaines qui
est un arbuste
pas très haut dos et raffole pourquoi
parce que il y a le sucre du bourgeon
mais il y a aussi dans la sève un
produit psychotrope imaginez-vous donc
ça fait beaucoup alcool et drogue je
vous apprends rien donc c'est pauvettes
mais pas du tout droit non non c'est le
site c'est le signe et il faut savoir
aussi qu'au printemps c'est les
chevreuils les jeunes de l'année
commencent à quitter leur moment à
s'émanciper donc c'est un peu la fête et
et voilà parfois le résultat donc si par
malheur vous
croisez croiser alors si vous le croisez
pas forcément de malheur mais bon si il
est coincé dans votre jardin mais tourne
la prochaine pas parce qu'un coup de
sabot est vite arrivé est-ce qu'il a
l'alcool gay l'alcool mauvais on ne sait
pas appeler la maréchaussée à savoir les
pompiers ou les gendarmes qui viendront
le récupérer et le remettre chez lui
après les fesses estompe assez
rapidement rassurez-vous et après si là
par malheur vous
vous êtes en voiture et vous tamponnez
un chevreuil voilà qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors imaginons la bête blessée sur le
sur le bas-côté vous appelez encore une
fois la gendarmerie et l'ofb normalement
viendra s'en occuper l'Office français
de la biodiversité voilà pour voir ce
qu'il faut faire de cette pauvre bête et
si terrible malheur mais ça peut arriver
la bête est tuée rebelote on appelle la
gendarmerie on donne son nom et soit
vous l'emportez dans votre coffre soit
vous trouvez quelqu'un qui en a l'usage
et qui va finir le chercher ou alors
vous essayez de le tirer sur sa parcelle
là comme ça pour que la nature fasse son
son œuvre et des charognards bien
évidemment ça vous est déjà arrivé au
château de Breteuil
je connaissais le l'ivresse des dieux au
bourgeons ça oui oui des chevreuils ce
qui est amusant on en a eu un pendant le
confinement qui est rentré dans le parc
qui se promenait alors évidemment il y a
plus de visiteurs et il était tout seul
il se promenait et il est tombé dans les
douves et dans les je sais pas si vous
savez nous avons des dents blancs alors
les dents blancs regardez ce cet étrange
cousin qui n'avait jamais vu le
chevreuil qui nous avons quand même
indiqué le chemin de la sortie mais il
revenait tous les jours il avait envie
de compagnie un cheval est rarement seul
c'est ça qui est bizarre donc il y a pas
d'eau dans les doubles
informations oui alors ma deuxième
horreur information pardon qu'on
consiste à en fait c'est une photo que
j'ai vu sur internet qui montre une
tombe dans un état de délabrement un peu
cassé à l'abandon et voilà c'est l'atome
de qui de du compte Robert de
Montesquieu qui est un Versailles alors
tout à l'heure on en parlait à vous
parler de Proust par exemple voilà on va
y aller exactement voilà Robert de
Montesquiou c'était un dandy poète un
peu insolent qui est fait partie des
amis de Proust et de Sarah Bernhardt par
exemple et on pense d'ailleurs que
Proust sans son est inspiré pour son
personnage du dans la recherche du temps
perdu et ce fameux compte de Montesquieu
à la fin de sa vie habite à Versailles
il avait acheté un pavillon qui
appartenait un écuyé du rôle Louis XVI
il la restauré il habitait avenue de
Paris donc bien évidemment lui et son
compagnon son compagnon
Gabriel itouri un argentin et mort avant
lui donc il lui a aussi des gonna érigé
un monument funèbre sur lequel il a mis
en son honneur très très grande statue
qui s'appelle l'ange du silence qui est
assez connu qui vient du château Vitry
c'est c'est montesquik qu'il avait
acheté donc après une fois décédé donc
quand est-ce que vous rejoint son son
compagnon et en fait cette statue qui a
disparu
mais en fait quand on se renseigne ce
sont les services de conservateur du
conservation du du cimetière des Gonnard
à Versailles qui
l'emprise car elle était tombée d'où
cette espèce cet aspect un peu délabré
et qui la restaurateur est donc
rassurons-nous elle va être bientôt
refixée à son poste c'est une très bonne
nouvelle en quelques secondes comme on a
pas trop le temps on va terminer avec la
troisième information un concert vous
voulez que j'aille très vite allez alors
c'est un concert qui se passe le 13 mai
vous en avez déjà parlé à voilà ça
s'appelle c'est à la table du roi la
table du roi c'est une table en pierre
qui est au confoin de cette route dans
la forêt de Rambouillet table du roi
c'est la Clusaz
j'imagine sur la table pour suivre ces
chasses ce qui avait une vue à 360
degrés on l'appelle aussi la table du
débotté parce que c'est la clé cavaliers
les dépit à terre et son restaurant
alors là il va y avoir un concert
classique donc en pleine forêt avec
notamment Olivia gay qui est une
violoncelliste et c'est le 13 mai on
part à pied des étangs de Hollande et
c'est l'association lips à qui a qui
l'initiative de ce concert alors
maintenant il nous reste à chuter
qu'aucun chevreuil ivre ne vienne
déroger ce moment voilà bah écoutez
merci beaucoup
pour toutes ces informations très
insolites dans le département et vous
nous les faites découvrir chaque semaine
et bah merci beaucoup et puis